the crypts of the st. mark's basilica
under more than a meter of water the
church one of Venice's most iconic
landmarks is among the worst-hit by the
flooding on Wednesday evening water
levels had gone down but locals remained
on the alert prime minister joseph
piccante rushed to the city to assess
the situation his government will
swiftly decide whether to accept the
regional governors appeal and declare a
state of emergency this stage I don't
see any reason not to declare a state of
emergency and begin allocating funds
immediately local authorities estimate
that more than 85 percent of the city
was inundated in the past days high
winds and heavy rain drove the water
level to almost 190 centimeters it
hadn't been this bad since 1966 mayor
Richard Lugar blamed climate change for
the extreme weather and said Venice was
on its knees there is also plenty of
anger here the most an undersea barrier
system aimed at protecting Venice from
high water has faced constant delays
since construction began in 2003
they've been on it for ten years but
they've done nothing it's in total
neglect it doesn't work and they've
stolen six billion euros in Italy
unfortunately that's the way it is our
politicians are all thieves they should
all be in jail as locals taking the
aftermath city officials say the damage
could total hundreds of millions of
euros Julie saw Delhi
Julius Adelie rather is in Venice
forests and assessing the damage Giulio
what's the situation in the city this
morning well this morning we were woken
by an alarm
high tide alarm in fact we are here in
st. Mark's Square you can see behind me
the
is rising again they expect to have a
new high tide this time around 130
centimeters so lower than the
record-breaking tide around 11:00 this
morning but life is going on as normal a
lot of tourists here taking pictures in
their rubber boots people here in the
city Venetians are assessing the damage
they're cleaning up their shops they're
cleaning up their homes hotels have been
affected cafes have been affected so
people are sort of trying to figure out
how much damage has happened how to go
on in the next few weeks but they're
also bracing for some upcoming bad
weather that is going to happen tomorrow
and Saturday now I understand Giulia
that even st. Mark's Basilica which I
believe is in the background there the
city's famous landmark it's been flooded
- how bad is the damage there yes the
Basilica has been flooded on the knot
Tuesday night water entered the Basilica
crept down into the Crypt and it flooded
it completely it also flooded the main
floor of the Basilica which is covered
in marble and mosaics now it's hard to
assess the damage quite yet because
experts have to wait for the water to
drain and to then conduct in-depth
investigations the problem is that even
once the water dries it's salty water so
the water will evaporate what salt will
remain and that can really really damage
the structures hmm well you know I
thought that Venice already had a flood
protection system I must admit what's
the story there why is it not ready so
construction of the mozi that's the name
of the protection system was meant to be
finished in 2014 it began in 2003 it
went on slowly it was filled with
controversy and scandal in fact in 2014
this system of barriers that was meant
to stop the high tide was investigated
for corruption and corruption ties were
found in the construction of the
barriers
should be completed now in 2021 but work
is slow and a lot of Venetians are upset
that this hasn't been completed yet and
they're asking why that hasn't happened
Julie what are the chances that Venice
will continue to face flooding will face
more flooding moving forward
well definitely a lot of people are now
talking about climate change as being a
factor in rising waters here in Venice
the mayor Luigi Bruni otto mentioned
climate change as a direct factor that
caused the high tide yesterday and
activists are also talking about the
influence of climate change so
definitely if there is a link there
there is a risk that events like this
will continue to happen and especially
if there is not a protection system in
place there is definitely a risk that
this could happen again Julia thank you
very much Julia saw Delhi their poorest
in Venice